what is right here there is something
right here itself crack in the table hmm
I'm still not sure how I feel about the
dark table I'm thinking I might need to
get something a little bit lighter
everything is still a work in progress
but anyway hello friends how are you
I've been meaning to make a video as a
follow-up to the event that happened at
Apple the other day and I had so much
fun because my sister and I went up to
the day we got to go to Cupertino we
went to the Steve Jobs theater and going
there is such an incredible experience
because everything is just so beautiful
we really lucked out because the day
that we went it was supposed to be an
eighty percent chance of rain and it
didn't rain at all it was so beautiful
okay so Jenna's filming for me so I got
a tire we're at the Apple event we're
all checked in here's our credentials
Jenna
she was tied big news it's also really
cold like surprisingly cold there's Sam
he's so super oh my god you like you
came prepared oh yeah California I don't
think by the way you do this every time
have you been to my god no oh I'm so
excited for you my first ever time just
enjoy
I do actually we are outside of the
Steve Jobs theater right now I'm so
excited to be here staff is over there
getting some pictures taken jenna is
filming for me and we're about to head
in for the event I'm so excited this
season with my tech friend and to see
what announcements they have for us
today
so this time to be Ben I brought a
backpack that also doubles as a bowler
bag so I've got my tripod I've got all
my gear and everything it fits nicely
inside of here and I don't have to put
it on my back because I'm so weak I
can't ever carry everything this is the
insert 361 camera and I have absolutely
been so obsessed with this Camberley
there's one camera that you guys need
it's this this thing is so cool I'll
show you guys a little shot that I'm
going to get around the theater
[Music]
there were some announcements and this
was a very interesting applicant because
basically what people were calling it
was a two-hour Apple commercial for
things that are not out yet normally a
lot of times at these events they'll
announce things and it's available
immediately after or within a month or
if your air power it just basically
never comes out you just kind of brush
it under the rug and act like it never
happened but we know we know it's there
it's somewhere we all have high hopes
that air power will one day make its
appearance but until then let's talk
about some of the things that they did
announce the first starting with Apple
news plus it's basically a subscription
that gets you access to over 300
magazines digital publications
newspapers and all kinds of things like
that so basically taking magazines and
newspapers and articles and beautifully
curating them into very well designed
pieces for your iPad iPhone Mac whatever
they made a mention in the keynote that
if you were to subscribe to all of the
outlets that you get with a $9.99 a
month subscription it would end up being
like $8,000 a year or something crazy
granted I don't think anybody would ever
actually subscribe to all of those
publications I'm kind of excited to try
this out because I used to read
magazines all the time and then I just
kind of stopped I'm not really sure why
I still do read Wired that's probably
one of the only magazine subscriptions
that I have because my grandmother
actually gets that for me as a gift and
it's so sweet because it not only
reminds me of my grandma but I get to
read all the latest tech news that's
basically the only thing that they have
available is the news plus I haven't
even signed up yet but I'm going to
right now try it for free so you have to
make sure that you update to the latest
iOS
we've got popular science Entertainment
Weekly time people Vanity Fair wired my
only magazine subscription that does not
look like Taylor Swift National
Geographic
it's cool because they said that they're
gonna have like animated covers like
look at that I think this is basically
kind of just reinventing and the way
that magazines are displayed take a look
at this this is actually pretty neat
okay all right National Geographic I'm
into it let me see something else like a
okay let's do People magazine ooh let's
see what this is like Britney Spears so
People magazine definitely as an as well
design just National Geographic claspers
you're basically curating the things
that it thinks that I'm going to want to
see and read so that's Apple News plus
I'm excited about the magazines mostly
another cool thing is a lot of these
features that they're adding all of
these different services is they are
available to your entire family so if
you do have a family plan with other
people underneath of your iCloud account
they'll also have access to the
subscriptions speaking of subscriptions
in case that wasn't enough later on
they're going to be coming out with
something called Apple arcade but I
think what they're trying to do is
further push the iOS development so by
having Apple arcade it seems like Apple
is now becoming a gaming publisher so
they're gonna be funding these different
games from different companies and then
you'll have access to these exclusive
titles under that subscription so this
is something I think is gonna be
interesting to see how this plays out
like will there be enough games that it
keeps people coming back and wanting to
subscribe for more like I'm not really
sure how this is all gonna work so I
feel like we don't really have enough
information or enough titles or enough
games to really be able to see how this
is all gonna play out but I do think
it's a great thing especially for
families and kids like if you just want
to play a bunch of mobile games like
you've got a subscription and endless
access swell plays is not that endless
news I think there's a way for 100 plus
games right now I think what's been
happening in this free-to-play market is
yes a lot of these games are free to
play but
to actually play them you have to spend
so much money buying supplies buying
power-ups buying all these add-ons that
by the time you get sick of playing the
game you've wasted so much money it's
insane
and I know this because I've definitely
made a lot of mistakes in some B's
free-to-play games like evenly clash of
clans and then like farmville back in
the day on Facebook like I said so much
money on farmville I'm embarrassed I
can't I don't even look what I think
about it I'm disgusted I still feel like
there's a lot of details that they
haven't announced about Apple arcade
like how do developers submit their
games and things like that so that's
gonna be cool to see how that all plays
out because they basically are giving a
platform for any developers to really
get their games out there and I think
that is something that is so important
because there's so many incredible games
but it's like how do you get people to
play them and definitely excited to try
that out and then you know what I want
to subscribe to all of these
subscriptions I can use my brand new has
a credit card now and you even believe
it I mean I sort of believe it but I
also don't believe it and this was
honestly one of the last things that I
thought that they would have ever
announced at this event when it popped
up on the screen it was I just I don't
know I didn't even know what to think
the main selling points of this credit
card is the way that it integrates
perfectly into Apple pay and into your
Apple wallet it also gives you a cash
back daily a lot of credit cards you
have to accumulate points and then you
can use it for other things and you have
to cash them in well every day no matter
what you spend you will get cash back so
you get 2% cash back on things that
aren't Apple related 3% cash back on
things that are at or related and I
think that you get 1% if you use the
actual card or places that don't except
Apple pay like look at this this is the
Apple actual credit card this is
optional because everything basically is
supposed to take place on your phone so
you don't really have a credit card
number you don't really have an
expiration date so on that card itself
which by the way is freaking titanium
with your name laser etched onto it of
course how Apple love you even if I
don't use this credit card like I
definitely like I have to get it like
I'm gonna have to do an unboxing of my
whole credit card well I do really like
about this
is the way that they're gonna be
organizing all of your spending a lot of
times when you look at credit card
transactions they were saying a lot of
the names you don't even know what the
heck you bought half the time of where
that purchase was made if we're using
Apple Maps they're going to figure out
the location the time the date and then
try to give you a sense of where you
actually purchase something and just by
looking at some of these mock-ups I
think it's a really great idea to be
able to have all of your spending
trapped in this way especially for
end-of-the-year taxes my only concern is
for me is I have a business account so
things tend to run a little bit
differently but maybe for my personal
spending this can be a really cool card
to try something that they didn't
mention in anything was what the
interest rates were if you read into the
fine print it says that the variable APR
is range from thirteen point two four
twenty four point two four based on your
creditworthiness so credit card Oh
reports of the average annual percentage
rate for all credit cards for banks in
2017 was twelve point five four which is
actually I mean that's that's lower than
what this rate is but of course that was
also in 2017 so I think a rate between
thirteen and twenty four is not that low
I mean if you have good credit and
you're on the lower side I'd love to
know what you guys think of the Apple
credit card I was seeing so many people
talking about this and some people were
like this is so cool some people like
this is so not cool I think the biggest
takeaway from all of this is the actual
credit card itself doesn't have your
credit card number on it you know
signatures no expiration dates
everything basically mostly is supposed
to take place on your phone but for
places that don't take Apple pay that's
where that optional physical card comes
in it's also cool because all of the
purchases are secure so everything
happens locally on your phone not on
Apple servers which means Apple won't
know what you bought how much you've
spent and it's cool because they also
use this one-time dynamic code to keep
everything super secure and obviously
you need your touch ID or your face ID
to actually make those purchases one of
the highlights though of the event
obviously was the Apple TV plus I mean I
think this is where you guys saw all
over the people talking because Oprah
came out on stage well actually they
open the whole event with a really cool
beautifully shot trailer of all of the
people that they're working with
JJ Abrams a Steven Spielberg Jennifer
Aniston Reese Witherspoon they'll talked
about the shows that they're working on
and what it's like to create and some of
their passions and it was just a really
well shot video I mean that's one thing
that Apple does right is those promo
videos look amazing so once that video
ended it was kind of crazy because the
entire theater just went completely
black and then a light just shined
directly on the middle of the stage and
Steven Spielberg was standing there as I
had guests in my predictions video I
feel like it'll probably be a
celebrity-driven I think they'll
probably have a lot of really cool
people out to talk about the shows that
they're working on they did just that
but it was a really cool experience
because seeing an Oprah on stage she
just has this presence about her that it
is just captivating
if you were in a room with Oprah you're
just gonna be like shocked I was I was
actually shocked one of the interesting
things is most of the shows that they
were talking about like they're not
ready yet and they didn't really even
have the trailers to show you didn't
have one transyl that they show the kind
of pieced together bits and pieces of
the shows that they are working on I
think that this is something that is
supposed to be launching in the fall
feel like leading up to that will
definitely hear more it was just so
interesting because they keep calling
you the platform for creative
storytellers so it feels like they're
really trying to set whatever this is
going to be way far away from like
Netflix and Hulu or something else we
understand you're gonna be watching your
Netflix but hey we've also got these
incredible people with curated
high-quality content over here on Apple
plus I'm certain addition to all of this
they also talked about Apple channels
basically you'll be able to subscribe to
individual channels so HBO or Starz any
of the other networks that they have
available set of just subscribing to a
whole cable package I guess you're gonna
be subscribing to iCloud arcade TV plus
I'm not even sure I've so many
subscriptions it's it's so overwhelming
when I just think about it either way I
think that the Apple TV plus the
streaming service is gonna be really
cool if there's one thing that Apple
does right is that is creating content
now I just keep thinking back to plan
into the apps that was just a fluke I
don't think that is anything that we can
even compare to what this is gonna be
like seeing JJ Abrams up there on stage
you guys ever saying like I'm a huge JJ
Abrams fan like massive I feel like we
are so just saturated with content to be
able to watch some shows that are
extremely high quality and produce by
really incredible people then obviously
they've got massive budgets behind
that's something that I can't wait to
see because obviously I mean I think our
YouTube content I mean I spend a lot of
money creating my content but it's my
own money
so it's a little different than having a
company come in and say hey we're gonna
give you a million dollars what would
you do with it sitting in a room alone
about my birthday card really my water
chapstick and extra microphone one year
Vermont day from today yesterday is your
birthday the thing that I unbox the
other day or chapstick all those
incredible light matte light which is
great I also just like here only the
finest for you guys well I just wanna do
a quick wrap-up because I didn't get a
chance to finish filming this video when
I got back from the event because it was
so late and I was really tired I said
you know what I'm gonna go to bed and
I'll make this video later and then
instead of doing that I unbox the air
pods so if you guys haven't seen the air
pods unboxing and I'll put a link in the
description and an annotation so you
guys can go check that out I'm really
loving the new air pots not that it
makes that much of a difference because
they sound I mean I don't think that I
can even tell the difference between the
old or the new but having that charging
case is so awesome just being able to
put it on my wireless charger and just
forget about it it's pretty great
that's it I will see you guys in my next
video I look forward to filming some
more fun things for you let me know in
the comments below what you thought of
the event what you'd like to see me make
videos about next and I think that's it
I see you guys later
[Music]